the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pass
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media listen i want to thank you
for your support if you're watching
please hit the subscribe button i'm
telling you it's a free way to help the
show if you have nothing out there you
say i want what can i do to help hit the
subscribe button that's what you can do
it's free to you it means nothing to you
and everything to us i promise the
patreon
continues to grow every month you guys
your stories are
mind-blowing all right we got a death
janitor who's out there cleaning up
suicides and everything else he's out
there cleaning up our messes the girl
that had two [ __ ] that came on she's
back with one [ __ ] we do the update on
that so it's five bucks a month if you
or someone you know has that story has
to be heard please submit it to
honeydewpodcast gmail.com
um you'll get the honeydew a day early
ad free at no additional cost and if you
sign up for a year you're getting over a
month free all right
you guys know what we do over here we
highlight the low lights i always say
these are the stories behind the
storytellers and today i'm very excited
to have here first time on the honeydew
y'all ladies and gentlemen please
welcome nick schwartz and welcome to the
honeydew nick sports center guys what's
up
that's what's up
what's up ryan thanks for having me
pleasure to be here listen thank you for
making this work yeah of course thank
you for repping all the golden girls and
the twins i know you're in minnesota
dude i'm covering everything then i just
went to the joshua tree and i got this
hat i saw you get out of the [ __ ] car
and i saw this and i was like yes
you know you almost got run over yeah
well i'll get into that but um yeah i
got this jacket uh a while ago like one
of those whatever it's called on
instagram or like
you just start by i was buying like
retro t-shirts so they would send me
like hey you want this and then they
sent me this and i was like oh i'm
[ __ ] yeah i want a golden girls
starter jacket is it actually it's not
an actual starter but it's like kind of
like that
so i bought one for me and my friend
alfonso and um we each have one and then
i always like weren't people like oh
cool and then i kind of in the back of
my head like i grew up in like the 80s
where you know you would get robbed for
having a star jacket 80s and 90s like
all that happened a lot where i grew up
so then i got i really got worried about
this where i was like oh somebody can
like jack me for this because i would
get compliments all the time and i'd be
like that'd be so funny if i got jacked
by like an 80 year old lady walking out
of like a nursing home and was like i
need that
just pulls out a [ __ ] glizzy and then
[ __ ] flip zip
butter and then when betty went past
passed away rest in peace then i got
[ __ ] hell in there
yeah cause then i was like oh no
i'm a walking target all the beatles are
gone nick yeah so don't [ __ ] rob me
if you see me wearing this
oh man all right i'm very excited to
talk to you but before we do promote
plug everything you want do it all
um
i got i'm so excited i got a bunch of
tour dates coming up so my website is
nicksworth.net
my dates are going to be posted soon i
don't know when this airs
but they'll be posted like within
a couple days oh this will be up yeah so
i've got a ton of dates coming up and
they're all club dates which is super
fun um orlando naples west palm beach
key west denver
uh brea irvine improvs um a bunch of
dates and then feeder dates
uh the wilbur and boston fox woods all
those in june minneapolis where i'm from
so i've got a bunch of dates coming up
and then if you can't make those i'm on
the cameo app
so i do cameos and stuff which are super
fun i do a lot of my characters if you
want me to do ingredients like terry or
dolph from just go with it those are the
two main ones or just me nick sportsman
that's what's up
i love it i i just had to talk with you
off camera about cameo cause i've been
unsure about it but you really uh i love
it yeah you put a good nice personal
spin on it yeah i mean it's one of those
things
where i was when i first started doing
it people were like oh you're doing that
and i'm like yeah it's [ __ ] fun and
for people that can't make a show i
don't charge like i remember
cameron who was they're like i don't
want to do it so i just put my price at
ten thousand dollars
ten grand yeah and so yeah mine's like
150 bucks and i make it super personal
like it's terry and whatever and then i
was like you know if you can't make a
show a price of a show is [ __ ] 40 45
bucks ticket 50 bucks maybe
and uh then you go dinner and drinks and
you know whatever parts like babysitters
all yeah but i make it really personal
and i really have fun doing it and it's
been great i have a blast you know what
i mean so
uh yeah if you want to do it if not come
to a show but the dates will be up
nextworthin.net i know it's annoying
it's fucking.net why is it that i don't
[ __ ] know man
betty white probably did it
all right so i know you're a minnesota
guy but outside of that i don't know
much about your upbringing so let's talk
a little bit be [ __ ]
disturbing
if you were like
in second grade i remember watching you
on the playground
so yeah i'm glad you don't know a lot
tell me about your mom dad siblings
stuff like that let's start there um no
my mom's back in minnesota with my
sister and brother my father passed away
um and
your dad passed 13 years ago okay
um we took him off life support on
thanksgiving oh that's great come on
yeah it's always great when somebody
dies close to you like on a holiday and
then that holiday just forever is like
that's the same pass the turkey yeah
remember when dad died today
anyway once turkey so hold on hold on
we're gonna start we're gonna just start
there
what how were you close with your dad
yeah i was very close to my dad he was
awesome he was a a writer really really
brilliant and um he wrote
he started as like a corporate job and
then he had a family and stuff and he
just wasn't a corporate dude
but you know he came from that era where
you know you had he got like you know
corporate job and then you had a family
and that's what you did and so him my
mom fought a lot and it was like weird
and then my mom left him so my brother
and sister weren't how old were you i
was
at the perfect age of
i was
13. okay which is
you know you're it that that's the start
of [ __ ] hitting the fan in general just
physically emotionally
so my mom was like no we're leaving so
we didn't tell my dad we just left and
packed our [ __ ] up yeah and her brothers
and stuff so we just dipped
in the middle of the night um no during
the day my dad was at work and you guys
were gone and we did you know what was
actually you were actually doing that
not really
i was like god we're taking a lot of
stuff to the store we're going up there
we're going grocery shopping
why are we bringing my bed to the
grocery store
it was like
and then she kind of like told me like
halfway through
she has like the oven she's like we're
getting the [ __ ] oh sorry i'm leaving
your dad we're getting the [ __ ] out of
here
i'm like oh all right
so we left our house and moved into an
apartment okay but your dad was good to
you guys it was just the day he was
great
so you and your brother and sister and
mom all my brothers away at college my
brothers and sisters were both away so
you're the youngest
yeah i'm the youngest so
you and your mom are an apartment in
minnesota now yeah in st paul okay and
we moved four blocks away which seemed
weird
so that wasn't even like that covert
it wasn't like yeah we're moving to
[ __ ] hawaii it was like no we're
gonna go four blocks away you're
probably
yeah so that was weird so what happens
when he finds out um he was confused and
angry
like a lot of people you think they'd be
like yeah all right i'm out but no
he was like bummed out and uh
it was really awkward and then obviously
and then he couldn't do the house so
then he got an apartment a block away
so he came closer yeah okay
and then uh and then he started writing
this is what kind of opened him up
and um he started writing and they were
amicable my mom my dad she's definitely
harbored more resentment
but uh what sort of writing
so he started writing for this pla this
publication called the city pages which
is like the la weekly it's like in any
town like the big like weekly
you know interesting artsy kind of
publication so he started writing for
them but he would write editorials and
stuff and he would freelance um he would
he i mean he got published in the
washington post he did a lot of [ __ ]
what he did that was really cool this
kind of sums him up
he came to visit me when i lived in l.a
i moved to l.a from minnesota i started
comedy then i lived in new york for a
couple years and i moved to los angeles
i moved to venice beach california
so he came to visit me in venice and i
lived off the boardwalk
and he crashed on my couch
and he was like what's going on here and
honest on every sunday there was riots
and a lot of gangs a lot of riots in
venice and my dad was like what is that
i'm like oh just every sunday like it's
these kind of like get together kind of
such riots and he was like oh
i want to know about that and he went
and [ __ ]
like talked to people and interviewed it
and did a story about it like i
published it in l.a weekly yeah wow all
right and he did this really sums him up
he [ __ ]
was curious about the united states
postal service and how they treated
their employees
and this keep in mind this is 20 years
ago also real quick that was a time when
going postal was a term and a thing you
don't hear that much anymore but there
was a minute where people at the time
were coming in and killing each other
yeah the whole thing yeah so he went
undercover
for the united states postal service and
worked for the postal service he like
really got a job he got a job and worked
like
long weird hours he worked over the
holidays he did all this stuff and then
wrote a whole kind of expose
about his experience wow all right yeah
and he just lived in this like
modest basement apartment i mean he
didn't need a lot of frills he was very
artistic anyway so that's my dad and
then my brother and sister are older and
they my sister's married with three kids
that are awesome and my brother's a
singer-songwriter oh yeah minneapolis
yeah okay
um so tell me more about your dad what
happens to your dad what you was on life
support so he got sick
he got a brain aneurysm man how old was
he um
21
shut the [ __ ] up
now he
this is so [ __ ] stupid and how
immature i am he was 69 years old and i
tell people he's 68 because i don't like
saying 69
so i literally tell people he's 68
because every time they're like how old
is your dad i'm like
69
and i just had a problem saying that so
they should just take that age away
just in case you die at that age so
people don't have to [ __ ] go through
that my grandmother unless you're not a
student oh really you really did she was
69. yeah i'm so immature that i can't
get over that
[ __ ] embarrassing so he was 669
and he was in the hospital and then me
and my brother i'll never forget this
we're standing over him well real quick
where was he when it happened um he was
in minnesota
was he working no he was in his um
apartment my brother went to go thank
god yeah i was gonna say luckily
somebody found them i think they were
supposed to go to lunch or something and
he wasn't answering the phone so my dad
my brother went over there and found my
dad just like [ __ ] zoned out or
whatever
and so we're over him in the hospital
bed and the doctor goes
yeah it's a really rare brain aneurysm
and um it's also uh hereditary
i mean my brother were like
you could have just not told us that
you could have just not said that
so now we're just like any time like i
have a headache or something like
like why the [ __ ] would you tell us that
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
so i we just mean how are you at the
[Laughter]
so yeah and some of you and my brother
are like [ __ ] all right
[Laughter]
but i'm not maybe i'll make it to 69.
so how how long did he last he had a
couple more strokes and then finally it
was just you know that was in years a
few years yeah it was yours he went to a
halfway house
and then it was just
you know we got him a cat and i think he
was like
he when we he couldn't handle the cat
the litter box was poopy and and he was
like oh maybe i gotta clean it maybe
i'll iron it and we were like okay bye
kitty
no
he never did iron the cat but he did i
think he didn't mention that one time
but no it was really sad and horrible
and uh if you've lost a parent i had
heard what it was like you know people
were like oh i lost my mom and i'm like
oh it's awful and they were like yeah
they're like you they're like have you
lost a parent at the time i was like no
and they're like it's
so awful and jarring
that you know whether or not you got
along with it whatever it is it's just
it's weird to just know that that side
of you you know mother or father is gone
yeah and i had a horrible time for years
and years saying that like people would
be like is your dad is your dad alive or
your parents and i'm like oh my mom is
that my dad's my dad died my dad's dead
and just saying that i would start
crying and that lasted for like a couple
years talk to me why well just saying
that sentence like oh no my dad is dead
and saying that to tears saying those
words yeah it would make me like well up
or i'm like oh [ __ ] you know my dad's
dead see i i don't envy you either i we
woke up you should i was
i was a great atheism uh my dad died and
we found him in his bed in the morning
oh [ __ ] but what i didn't have was a
parent like i realized like oh some of
my friends now their parents are getting
older and they're some are suffering
dementia some are having to go into home
some are having health issues where i
think about it i'm like man i didn't
watch this this man i consider to be
superman
slowly
die and wither away i just we just woke
up and it was boom it's over yeah that's
40 [ __ ] horrible it's a it's a big
difference that's what i want to ask you
like what is it like to watch to see
that and then to think the whole time
like holy [ __ ] this could happen to me
because i've now found out that the the
thing i've seen
in that bed is hereditary oh wow oh yeah
what was it it was um heart clots blood
clots that's [ __ ] horrifying in
general because that can happen to
anybody anytime but i have a blood
disease that i now know but i didn't
find out i was cause they think it's
everything back then this is the 89 is
heart attack if you're young it was
heart attack heart attack and now
they're realizing that a lot of that was
probably blood clots yeah you know
whether it broke off in your you know
heart brain lungs whatever
um they'll they go and they he had left
he had had a heart attack left the
hospital they said you do have a blood
clot we're releasing you thanksgiving
weekend
and
we were i've told this it's crazy it was
he gets out we spent thanksgiving in
baltimore city with my at my aunt's
place because he was right by hopkins
johns hopkins that's where you got out
and then we go back to our place in in
carroll county on uh sunday night and
monday we have off because it's a
thanksgiving holiday and they're giving
us that uh thursday friday monday
and that monday i have a date with one
of the prettiest girls in school and
i've been wanting to go out on a date
with this girl and when we wake up my
dad's dead and there goes
everything their whole life changes and
it's thanksgiving so i'm with you on
like thanksgiving and christmas are
soured like that whole
time that whole house
same things
yeah so when you said thanksgiving it
[ __ ] hit you're saying 69 my
grandmother was 69. she was right after
him so is that true you're stealing this
from me i feel like that's the point of
your podcast is just steal people's
lives from them
i'm happy oh that's weird what was your
dad's name
no that's
so i'm yeah that's hard i get you on and
you i mean seasonal depression or
whatever the [ __ ] you want to call it
but that [ __ ] is
thanksgiving to christmas is tough
sledding a lot yeah no that's brutal i'm
sorry for your loss that's awful but you
so you know it's just weird when you go
oh yeah they're dead
it's like but you're you're watching it
and that's different i discover it
you're you're seeing a difference in a
person over time yeah which is so hard
and that that happens and that's why i
feel just horrible for people that have
to go through that especially
alzheimer's all that horrible things is
to watch somebody mentally deteriorate
you know somebody that you know was so
vivacious and hungry and right loved you
know love life and who they were and
that was he still able to keep up with
his writing in a sense like did he try
to record things he had to stop break
dancing
[Music]
that was one thing that was really hard
he
did it up until the end he did one last
head spin
and then
he was taken
he was taken
um
terrible so
he um
he did right the saddest this is even
[ __ ] sadder
so
um i grew up a big duke basketball fan
i love i love duke i don't know i [ __ ]
since i was a child i remember watching
them on tv and there was just something
about the best
so long story short
i for somebody like i would gotta try to
their jerseys like that royal blue and
everything and
um i liked them before they were
anything in the 80s so long story short
i've been a duke family my whole life so
and i love coach
he's just such a class act phenomenal
coach best coach
so
um uh he
coach k wrote a book called leading with
my heart
and i read it and it was great
and
the last thing my dad gave me was a copy
of that book and he gave it to my
brothers my brother my sister me
and he wrote in the book um
the last thing that he could physically
write and he wrote
um my dear nicholas uh i'm leaving you
with this this will fill in the blanks
for all the stuff that i wasn't there
for couldn't do
and i'm so sorry about that but
hopefully this book will help you
because my dad had read it he goes
hopefully this will help you fill in the
blanks and i love you
and uh yeah
pick
wow
so that's the last thing that he gave me
still haven't obviously i didn't sell it
you didn't pawn them i gave it away in
that show
i just gave it to somebody in the crowd
like here's to fill in the blanks i
don't know what your life is
but yeah so he that was the last thing
that he pretended
yeah so and then he has to go in and say
i'm scared of this i don't want to go
into a home because once you go into the
home that's it they just they just
medicate you on all the way out i feel
like yeah i mean i don't know i'm just
going to stay i like give about my
daughter's
i'm down to go above your garage
yeah i don't know what i mean just a
fridge and a little [ __ ] microwave
that's all i need then i'm down to just
grab some [ __ ] h dude with some black
tar
you know what if i make it to my 80s and
you really want to do that i'll come
over
i mean i remember
i remember um
some it was bill hicks
almost sure was bill hicks freaking me
if it's not but he talked about
terminally ill patients doing stunts and
movies to die
which is so genius
it's so brilliant
and that's how i mean i think that's how
it should be yeah if you hope anybody
can i'm almost trying to bill him die
hard six yeah that sounds like bill
hacks just go off a cliff and [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah dude and it looks real as [ __ ]
[Laughter]
but the other thing you put
the other thing you point out two things
another joke again [ __ ] i'm having brain
farts um almo i almost think it was dave
attell who yeah he who said i always
thought my father was a superhero and it
turns out he was just an alcoholic with
a cape
it's not the cape yeah i think it's dave
again if it's not i'm almost sure it is
so forgive me if it's not forgive me but
um one thing you touched on is people
are like oh your dad he died he was so
young you know so soon too soon
and i thought the similar thing when i
was like actually 70 69
that's about it's a solid time to get
the [ __ ] out because it's not getting
greater you know what i mean which is
kind of a weird way to think but you
know he did circumvent you know i mean
even though we got a [ __ ] aneurysm
but it was you know so many horrible
things happen like
as you get older and older and older but
you know hopefully not but well guys
said to me in the crowd the other night
i don't wish my dad would have died by
the way don't
misconstrue that
he said my biggest fear is dying young
and i said well how old are you because
i'm 33 and i go well listen
you're past young you're too young to
die but you're not young you know what i
mean like you're 33 you're 30 you're
three decades into this [ __ ] thing
yeah so yes it would be tragic if you
died right now i'd be too young to die
but bro you're you're not nine
you know what i mean you're not [ __ ]
15 16 i know people that died in high
school you know we all same here
um okay so your dad passes and what is
it like with your mom does your mom
is it affect her in a way or were they
distant enough
no
i felt like that was her best like
acting performance
because she was like we're like yeah we
pulled the plug on dad and she was like
oh
that's terrible
no
or like she i think she might have like
pulled it like right before us
like she [ __ ] pulled it out and then
like plugged it back in
and then like hit in the closet or
something
did you actually have to sign paperwork
i don't remember i have no idea my
brother probably did yeah
um were you there when they actually
turned the machine off no i was there
right before we had our goodbyes and
then
my mom stuck in but uh no i wasn't i
didn't physically was a part of that
but yeah it was weird
and then how was the funeral
um it was interesting it was interesting
like who didn't show up because this was
pretty coveted
so that's what he didn't have an excuse
yeah yeah so it was interesting who did
and who didn't and i had to speak i
didn't mean i didn't have to but i
wanted to and this is another thing i
wrote kind of
a lot of jokes because that's just what
you do like that's as you're when you're
a comedian like your brain is so wired
to being a comedian at least i know me
and a lot of comics are just like you
always go for a joke just out of
um
well just out of instinct you don't
always say it or whatever but you just
you think it so that's why when i'm in
situations all the time i'm always like
i'll just start laughing and people are
like what and i'm like and it's just
something that i think in my head but i
don't say it
so when i was writing my dad's eulogy
i had all these jokes about him and the
second i hit the pulpit
i [ __ ] lost it and i just
read some of it no jokes at all i just
was crying so hard i couldn't
get through it and i i just barely did
and um i just the only thing i remember
from it your mom's out there like let's
go
[ __ ] wrap it up my mom's like get me up
there
this [ __ ] did this
um
but i remember the last thing i said as
i go
i've always been afraid to die
and now i'm not because i know my dad is
up there and he did it and if he can do
it i'm not afraid anymore
that was the last thing i said
and then i immediately went to the bar
yeah [ __ ] up
yeah
still am
now do you solve tequila
all tequila today's program is brought
to you by athletic greens the health and
wellness company that makes
comprehensive daily nutrition really
really simple with so many stressors in
life it's difficult to maintain
effective nutritional habits and give
our bodies the nutrients it needs to
thrive busy schedules poor sleep
exercise the environment or simply not
eating enough of the right foods can
leave us deficient in key nutritional
areas all right i'm taking an ag-1 scoop
every single day i don't always eat
right i don't always have the time i say
i know everybody probably could but
i'm coming home late nights from
tour different time zones i'm out on the
road i take it with me one tasty scoop
of ag-1 contains 75 vitamins minerals
and whole-food-sourced ingredients
including a multi-vitamin multi-mineral
probiotic green superfood blend and more
in one convenient daily serving the
special blend of high quality
bioavailable ingredients in a scoop of
ag-1 work together to fill the
nutritional gaps in your diet support
energy and focus aid with gut health and
digestion and support a healthy immune
system effectively replacing multiple
products or pills with one healthy
delicious drink join the movement of
athletes moms dads rookies first timers
and everyone in between taking ownership
of their daily health and focusing on
the nutritional products they really
need in the simplest manner possible to
make it easy athletic greens is going to
give you an immune supporting free one
year supply of vitamin d and
five free travel packs with your first
purchase if you visit athleticgreens.com
honeydew today again simply visit
athleticgreens.com honeydew to take
control of your health and give a g one
a try what would you do if you didn't
have high interest loans or credit card
debt would you move to a new city would
you start a family through upstart you
can pay off your existing debt quickly
with a personal loan so you can tackle
your next big financial goal whether
it's paying off credit cards or
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses over one
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date upstart knows you're more
than just your credit score so rather
than looking at your credit score alone
upstart's model considers other factors
like your income employment and other
information provided in your loan
application to find you a smarter rate
for your loan and you can check your
rate without impacting your credit score
in just five minutes for loans between 1
000 all the way up to 50 000 and you can
even receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com honeydew that's
upstart.com honeydew don't forget to use
my url to let them know i sent you loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com honeydew
it's funny there are all these gimmicks
that promise a great night's sleep and i
don't care what kind of toppers there
are how heavy a blanket may be it's
lipstick on a pig if you are sleeping on
a terrible mattress your sleep will be
terrible it's that simple that's why i
recommend sleeping on a purple mattress
that's because only purple mattresses
have the gel flex grid it's a super
stretchy ultra squishy material that
adapts and flexes around pressure points
and doesn't retain heat unlike memory
foam which remembers everything thanks
to the gel flex grid purple mattresses
bounce back as you move and shift and
you'll never have that i'm stuck feeling
people get with memory foam my wonderful
producer kirsten here she and her
husband just got a purple mattress they
love it i got one for my daughter i got
a queen size and i'm telling you we
moved out of my bed into hers and we sit
there and read books and sleep so try
your purple mattress today risk free
with free shipping and returns and
financing is available too getting a
great night's sleep starts with having a
great mattress get a purple mattress go
to purple.com honeydew and use code
honeydew for a limited time you can get
10 off any order of 200 or more that's
purple.com
honeydew code honeydew for 10 off any
order of 200 or more purple.com honeydew
promo code honeydew terms apply now
let's get back to the do do you um do
you watch your health are you keeping an
eye on yourself with this brain aneurysm
thing do you even there's i mean it's so
arbitrary i mean i keep an eye on my
health it's funny because i'm an extreme
dichotomy of really really healthy
and then if i don't want to be really
really not at all
and that that's all
all alcohol i mean i've
i've done every drug but i've never i'm
not a drug user at all i don't even
smoke weed which people baffles people
still
but um yeah i love drinking but i'm also
like this is a plant-based protein shake
with like almond milk like i i take a
[ __ ] load of vitamins and stuff like
that are you still drinking now today no
not at all i've been drank for a couple
months okay three months
so yeah we had kind of talked about that
tell me about this story i want to hear
a little bit about this well a lot of my
fans and people know that i you know i'm
a drinker i've always promoted it i've
got tons of drinking jokes can i just
say this really quickly yeah i want to
give you props while you fill up your
your drink
that [ __ ] monkey high five bit it is
it is it's an absolute classic for me
it's up there with every
great [ __ ] comedy bit you've ever
seen get the [ __ ] smile oh thanks oh
you see the [ __ ] monkey dude it's so
goddamn good so i know you're a big
partier from back in the day first let
me ask you where does that come as come
from is that just a is are you were your
family drinkers mom dad drinkers
brothers like where does the drinking
come from so it comes
this is where it stems from and i'll
just say really quick for those of you
that don't know um my
special seriously who farted there's a
story about what
when i was in vegas
and long story short and it's a true
story just youtube better look it up or
with the special salad but
monkey high five iconic and it's it's
really really funny true story about me
losing a lot of money by high-fiving a
monkey anyway
when my parents got divorced when i was
13
again pivotal time and that's junior
high i'm starting that
and my mom had to work three jobs
because my dad had no money he had quit
his corporate job and he had nothing so
my mom worked three jobs which left me
alone
and
going into junior high and it was just a
very cliche i started smoking
started drinking and my friends were
just [ __ ] ragers we were getting the
alcohol at home or from like friends or
brothers but your mom did have some
around you would not really my mom and
dad were not drinkers okay no i mean
they did you're getting into everywhere
casually yeah so we would just
me and my buddies who i still talked to
were all just you know
we were [ __ ] no joke dude we were
i mean
cutting class selling drugs doing any
drug you could we could get our hands on
in eighth grade ninth grade oh yeah i
mean i
i had court-ordered rehab by the time i
was 16.
oh i
wow i've talked about this before but um
we were [ __ ] insane dude me and my
friends were [ __ ] insane we were
stealing cars some of my friends went
into gangs i mean we were
i mean like i said we're selling drugs
what are you selling weed
usually weed and pills
but i remember
like i went to a very inner city school
and people think like oh simple
minnesota it's like no it was you know
it's ignorant to go like oh yeah i'm
sure it was like [ __ ] crazy it was
like no it was legit
there's tons of gangs tons of drugs
there's a lot of [ __ ] going on
and uh yeah so i remember i started
selling weed and i was i guess on the
wrong turf or whatever
and so my mom and keep in mind i'm like
this little blonde sweet kid
so you thought
and um
i came home and my mom goes
what is going on
what are you doing and i go what do you
mean and she goes this guy called her
house
and um
he threatened to kill me and you
and i go
that's weird
and she goes
yeah he said you're selling drugs and i
go
no
i got it's probably the wrong number and
she goes
it's your name nick swartzen
yeah that is my name it's weird
and she's like whatever you're doing
stop and i was like
so i stopped selling drugs death threats
holy yeah [ __ ] dude yeah i do like
damage control to like go back i'm like
hey can somebody
talk to so-and-so
tell them to not do that please because
i knew who it was
but um yeah so anyway yeah court ordered
rehab why what did you get caught with i
got caught smoking a blunt during school
during school which is weird because i
got on the property yeah in school in it
yeah me and my friends were smoking
during theater class which is so weird
and kind of full circle not full circle
but beginning of a circle where i was in
the balcony while the theater class was
going on i was in 10th grade
and we smoked a blunt and of course a
[ __ ] blunt as you know the smoke just
goes
right on stage
the teacher who became my acting teacher
called the principal they called the
police please kicked in the door
handcuffed us and walked you got a
handcuffed at school handcuffed i was
[ __ ] baller as [ __ ] dude
16 years old during lunch period are you
crying no [ __ ] no
[ __ ] nick swartz and dog i had a
[ __ ]
no i was [ __ ] come on
i was but in my head i was like [ __ ]
because i know my mom was gonna flip
and so we got walked out and was
court-ordered i was gonna get expelled
but i had to do it
what did you have to do what was the
reason i had to go to classes and all
that [ __ ] after school and [ __ ] yeah and
i had to
take like piss tests and [ __ ] you did
yeah and how long did you have to stay
could they test for alcohol it's just
blood right it was just blood but i mean
i took it down a notch because you know
obviously it was a big [ __ ] deal and
so but you didn't get expelled from the
school yeah it didn't get expelled and
then how long was the rehab last it was
like a month do you remember any
people's stories the [ __ ] they share and
there anything no because it was all
teenagers so we were all pricks you know
what i mean we're like what the
[ __ ] like right
stupid
so
then i um
that summer after that i just kind of
decided to clean up
like i'd hit a wall with doing so many
drugs and so i was just tapped out
and so are you playing sports at all
yeah i always played sports and i turned
my back on him when i was playing drugs
and when you were playing when i was
playing
drugs
so
my mom was like
she god bless her she was like pushing
me to stay and
stay in sports which was so important
like kids out there like sports are
really important it's a release of also
like what you're going through
so i played soccer and tennis
super gangster
and uh
i did that and then i just cleaned up
and i decided like i was like oh i gotta
[ __ ] pull the plane up now i'm going
into my junior year my grades were and i
was a smart dude but i just didn't pay
attention cause i was telling you i was
smoking nonstop
so i just did that i started from
scratch my junior year my friends all
left school they went to other schools
like art schools and just kept doing
drugs or whatever
so i just started school even though i
knew everybody it was a big school but i
just started alone i had no friends i
mean i knew people but i was just alone
and i like
wasn't me anymore like the old me and
then i started taking acting as an easy
grade so i was like i need to get my
grades up i'll take feeder
so i took intermediate theater and the
teacher was like
who the [ __ ] are you is this the same
teacher that called the cops on you yeah
okay
and i go nick schwartzen and she's like
where did you come from she's like
you're i did a monologue and she's like
you're really really good
and i go i was the [ __ ] dude in the
balcony
and she was like what
i'm like yeah i'm the guy that got high
and arrested
and i go i cleaned up now and i just i
need an easy grade can you give me an a
and then she was like kind of offended
she was like well no theater's not easy
like i'm just going to give you an a
but she's like you're really [ __ ]
good so i did it like a semester with
them she goes i'm moving up to the
touring company and the advanced thing
and i'm like oh and so i did that and
then i you know i got addicted to acting
so the great thing about doing that was
it replaced my my love of drugs and that
high okay and then i started doing
improv there's an improv company called
comedy sports that came to my school
and i started doing that and then i just
became obsessed with acting and comedy
and my best friend became this uh
comedian actor colton dunn
colton's an improviser he's on the show
superstore he's yeah i know wheel and
chair he's alright he was a performer
writer for conan he just did everything
so me and him
just [ __ ] went off and did that we
moved to new york and it was crazy
but yeah i mean i it literally saved my
life it took over everything i threw my
whole
world and uh acting in comedy and then
after high school i started stand up
okay
but when did you start drinking again
so when i started stand up i was like
really determined to succeed okay and i
i started again in minnesota
and stamped to me was easy because i
knew what you were gonna say like doing
improv is [ __ ] hard because it's
scary because you don't know what's
gonna happen yes
so stand up i was like oh i know what
i'm gonna say i mean it was still scary
as [ __ ] because it's just you on stage
but um i was really focused when i
started stand up and i'm like the
fastest way to get discovered and
noticed is to be clean
and to tell jokes i can tell in any
state and tell on tv that everybody will
get where the local comics would do like
everything very provincial and very like
local
and you know they would all drink and
party and [ __ ] and they weren't as
focused and i'm like [ __ ] this i'm
[ __ ] gonna work at this [ __ ]
and a lot of people help me but for the
most part the club owners were like keep
writing and i did and then whatever so i
got discovered by hbo after six months
of open micing damn all right they
picked me as one of the top young comics
in the country
and then they brought me to the aspen
comedy festival so from my first open
mic i got picked by hbo i signed with
three yards with chris rock's manager
and then i was in the comedy festival
after one year and then i did stand up
on nbc
uh comedy showcase with louis anderson
so it's [ __ ] insane someone saying
what a year yeah and then it just
everything got [ __ ] not then it just
took off and i started doing more and
more stand up then i moved to new york
and it was crazy
and then i didn't really start drinking
drinking years after that where i really
started drinking where i would drink all
the [ __ ] time
and uh you know it never affected my
work or anything but like i just fell in
love with drinking
i loved it it was awesome
you i remember a story you told me
actually i think that you you showed up
i don't know if you went and slept in
your car or where but you came into the
improv at like 10 in the morning on like
a saturday and you're like guys i can't
remember where i parked
oh yeah
yeah i lost my car that's it lost your
car you didn't sleep with it you lost
that yeah i lost it
and then tmz found it
that right
i'd gone to the comedy club and this is
back when i was drinking and driving
which is [ __ ] horrible of course if
anything i can leave anybody with
anything do not [ __ ] drink and drive
it is the worst and there's no excuse
call a friend call an uber call lift do
not drink and drive anyway
i went to the club i was so drunk i
couldn't walk and then these comics took
me home somebody else drove my car
this is what i was told after the fact i
couldn't remember my gate code so they
parked it on the street
and i went walked back to the club i
didn't live far from there
and i couldn't find my car in the lot
and i was like [ __ ] and i remember who
drove me home so i was like my car's
stolen so then i just went on a bender i
didn't even care it was a [ __ ] jaguar
it was a nice car
and uh i just went on a bender and i
just drank and tmz pulled over when i
was walking down the street
and they're like nick swartz and i'm
like what's up and they're like what are
you doing i'm like drunk which is really
smart to tell tmz but luckily they've
always been so nice to me
and they were like why and i go i don't
know i go i lost my car
and they're like you lost your car to go
it was stolen they're like what was it i
go black jaguar xfr and they're like
okay and so they put it on the show
they're like nick sports and lost jaguar
black xfr my [ __ ] neighbor was
watching tmz
called me
hey did you think you lost your car i'm
like yeah sad and they're like it's
right down the street
it's a half a block down the street and
i go no and i went outside and there it
was
and then i got a hold of tmz and then
they posted like we found nick's car
all right so like i've never hated on
tmz i never did it anyway but
it was the thing where i was always like
thank you harvey levin
well you told me that you had gotten to
a point where you were drinking so much
did you not you got alcohol poisoning i
got alcohol poisoning a lot so i started
drinking a shitload and a lot of people
what you asked me is they're like are
you an alcoholic are you yeah on alcohol
i'm not at all but it's so weird i don't
know if anybody else is like this but
it's a weird thing where i'm not
dependent at all like i don't crave
alcohol i don't i can i can hang in a
bar all [ __ ] day and watch football
and drink bottled water easily
so i just love drinking and then i would
get frustrated with certain things and
parts of my life and things so i would
drink and you know kind of numb it out a
little bit but i for the most part i
just always loved drinking it was just
really fun and i would always have funny
stories like blacking out and [ __ ] like
i talk about in my act i do jokes about
it
and uh
i i it was just always fun for me like
after a show is a release and i've drank
with fans a billion [ __ ] times i mean
i always have so much fun drinking but
you know i would get in the rut of
you know i would drink
i would just keep going if i had time
off and i would take breaks from acting
and stuff and if i had like two months
off i would drink for two months
straight for real i mean wake up
literally
wake up go to the bar
go pass out nap uh have lunch and then
go drink until two in the morning damn i
would start drinking at 6am till 2 a.m
daily
daily i would do it back to back to back
to back back
and that doesn't like but i wouldn't
drink like when i was filming i would i
would always like clean yeah on time off
yeah but you don't you don't throw up
you're not hungover or you are and you
just drag yourself that's the thing
that's the thing about when you drink
like that
you don't get hungover because you
constantly have alcohol in your system i
see there's so after a while i didn't
even i didn't even know what hangovers
were i would just keep going
so when i got into the hospital and
that's when you asked me about my low
point
was i had
just wrapped a movie the wrong missy
with me and david spade it's awesome i
watched it yeah
and
i dried out
and um i remember i had some show i was
developing
and it fell through and i was like
really [ __ ] pissed because it's
really hard i've developed tons of shows
and they all fall through the cracks or
like you get [ __ ] over by a network or
whatever these executives that love that
they got promoted or they're leaving
something new people don't want your
[ __ ] always something so this and a lot
of people go like how come you don't
have your own choke
and i'm like dude you don't understand
how hard it is and how much you work
even like at the level i was at where
like with comedy central i would develop
all these shows and they would fall by
the wayside so i was working so hard and
so finally i was at that point i was
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] this
i'm gonna get [ __ ] drunk
as much as i [ __ ] can so i took a
whole summer i did some stand-up shows
but i got [ __ ] housed i traveled all
over i went back to minnesota i went to
games i'm like i just want to go to
baseball games i went to baseball games
i [ __ ] hammered
and i came up like so june july august
hit september
and i'm just drinking the whole time all
that time [ __ ] whole time what do you
drink anything at that time
i i just threw all my like drinking
rules out of not just beer no i wasn't a
beer guy i was [ __ ] vodka okay and
then you know somebody would throw in
fireball or some [ __ ] or whatever
so
i just got [ __ ] housed and then i had
shows coming up and i didn't realize it
but i woke up in minneapolis and i
didn't feel good at all like i and it
was something where i wasn't used to
where i'm like something's wrong
and uh my buddy picks me up takes me to
the airport and i go hey man something's
off and he goes uh you [ __ ] you've
been drinking whatever who cares
and i'm like
okay so i go to the airport go to the
bar
have a cocktail
i [ __ ]
this it gets funnier when i almost die
so
oh yeah
i love airport bars by the way so i go
to the airport bar have a cocktail go to
the bathroom throw it up i'm like ugh
i get on the plane it's not normal
you're not ever throwing up okay so i'm
like uh my stomach i haven't eaten
anything
so and i'm throwing up bile like the
yellow bar ugh but i'm no stranger to
them
so i [ __ ] throw up going on the plane
and i'm like now i'm getting a weird
pain
and i'm like okay that's weird so i'm
like can i get a cocktail whatever so i
got a vodka
drink it and there's a guy next to me on
his laptop getting work done
and i drank the cocktail and you're
going from la to where how long is your
flight okay a few hours so not that bad
so no no minnesota denver sorry and um
so i go oh [ __ ] and so i have to throw
up i don't want to bother this guy so i
took my carry-on and threw it up into it
you did not yeah i threw up the cocktail
[Music]
and then i put it down yeah this is how
[ __ ] bonkers i go can i get another
cocktail
they give me another one
so my my method
my method was always you can drink
through it yeah all right the worst i've
ever been like i'm always like just
drink through it and i don't know if
anybody else is this kind of [ __ ]
drinker but
usually by the third cocktail i break
even and i'm like oh okay my anxiety
everything's gone
so
i do another cocktail [ __ ] i throw it up
again come on and now just hadn't
noticed at all i think pretty sure he
did yeah i thought i was being subtle
it's really hard to subtly vomit you
know yeah
it's time to be like
where it like perfectly goes out
like i'm sure i thought i was being
slick but i was like
so
i am
i get this pain are you all so scared
that like holy [ __ ] i hope not the land
is playing for me no i i didn't i was
like
oh i go i got this
so get this pain there's pain that's
getting worse
so i get off the plane and i go right to
the bar denver
right to the bar
another cocktail this one stays down
then i have another one i'm drinking
vodka and bitters
trying to settle my stomach and then i
get a banana that's one of my go-to's
they get a banana
and then all of a sudden i'm like [ __ ]
and i go to the bathroom and i throw it
all up and now the pain is getting
really bad without like a burning it was
like a real intense burning and now i'm
worried now i'm really worried and i'm
like oh no so i had two options check in
a hotel room just go to sleep take a nap
or go to an urgent care
so i called my agent and i go hey
something's wrong he's like where are
you i go denver airport something's
really really wrong
i go i think i'm going to go to an
urgent care and he goes um okay
and i'm like i'll call you back so i go
to the urgent care in denver outside the
airport and i show up first of all i
like looked it up and they had a yelp
review and it was one star
this is a true story and i go oh
i'm like what the [ __ ] how do you [ __ ]
up in urgent care
like it was insane but i had no choice
i'm like okay let's go let's see
hopefully
and um
i go and i walked one star
yeah one star urgent care so i show up
and the woman behind the counter is like
okay i just need to talk to a doctor and
she goes
oh no you need an ambulance just like
that yeah and i go
what i don't know and she goes no you
need an ambulance call's an ambulance
some medics come
and um what does she see i don't know so
i'm in this room
and the paramedics come and i'm throwing
up
and uh
they're like hey and i go i think i'm
fine and they're like no and they're
like looking at me like do you know
where you are they ask me all these
questions because another thing is when
you drink an altitude i went into an
altitude oh that's right so that hit me
hard
but then i could answer all these
questions and the guy goes you and
grandma's boy i'm like yeah yeah let's
just that was good let's talk about that
let's talk about that like later please
and they were like we need to get you to
a hospital now
and i'm like uh [ __ ] and they loaded me
into the ambulance and they put me on
all these [ __ ] tubes and ivs this is
the brain aneurysm and that's yeah here
it is i wish
so i'm in the back of the hospital and
that was the lowest point and i started
crying because i was alone
and i'm going to a hospital and i don't
know what's going on
and i was just sitting there and i
remember just tears going down my face
and i was like holy [ __ ] i finally hit
the [ __ ] biggest wall
you could hit
and then long story short
i was in the er university colorado um
and i was there for three weeks weeks
three weeks
keep in mind
somebody with the quadruple bypass heart
surgery
um will be in the hospital for three
days
holy [ __ ] and i was there for three
weeks so i had necropancreatitis what is
that it's not good
it's not a bag of [ __ ] skittles
so i had necropancreatitis pneumonia
blood sepsis
that's top that's poison right blood
poison
um altitude sickness and alcohol
poisoning holy [ __ ] all at once
so it was hell on [ __ ] earth i don't
remember a week and a half of it really
i did major surgeries they cleaned up my
lungs my stomach they had to actually do
surgery they had to do they had to go
into my body yeah pull out all this [ __ ]
and three um three weeks i was there and
when i finally got out it was awful but
i there was weeks where i would only i
could only eat ice cubes and ice chips
and it was
i mean i was non-stop getting blood work
blood work tubes everything diarrhea all
over the [ __ ] place why the whole
time you're in there oh if i went to the
diarrhea nationals i would have placed
[ __ ] first easily
i would have i mean like full goal
diarrhea
yeah i would have [ __ ] walked away
easily with the [ __ ] gold
so
the doctor goes he goes just my family
flew in they all flew in i was going to
ask that people come visit it was like
this is it and two comics really helped
me that was supposed to open for me in
colorado springs ted evans and david
hunsberger they're both really funny and
they were able to
track me down because my phone they had
some so my phone rang and i guess
somebody answered it in the er i see or
whatever the hospital
and they came and they got a hold of my
family so god bless ted evans and david
hunsberger again very funny comics so
i got out of the hospital and the doctor
goes you had a 10 chance of living what
he goes one of those things could have
killed you the necro pancreatitis for
sure pneumonia for sure blood steps is
if it had gone to your heart you'd be
dead and altitude sickness with alcohol
poisoning it's like both those things
you can you can get sick from and die
from and he goes you get all five at
once so the fact that you don't have a
colostomy bag permanent brain damage
he goes
and uh i was like holy [ __ ]
you almost drank yourself to brain
damage and death i almost completely
yeah completely [ __ ] ended at all so
three weeks you're in there i imagine
that three weeks if it's just alcohol
you're fully detoxed at least your blood
they've probably done everything they
can yeah they were like yeah so like
what's life like they want out of there
i was very weak obviously i didn't
[ __ ] do a cartwheel out of there so i
like hobble on the plane get home i
changed my diet i gotta fly
oh yeah decided to fly home
and you know i just put out the
the apb to my roommate my friends and
everything and
you know i got home and i just changed
my diet i mean my diet was never bad
that's one thing that probably saved me
is the vitamins and diet that i was on
like i always ate healthy even though i
was a [ __ ] mess
but um yeah so i just detoxed and then
[ __ ] covet hit
so i somehow got circumvented that
getting that
but i sobered up for like nine months
and i didn't drink at all or even think
about it and um
so yeah
and then what then you went to key west
so then covet hit that was insane i did
a couple shows
um right before are you the entire time
between you getting out of the hospital
and covet are you
staying off of alcohol yeah 100 percent
you are okay but yeah
think about it and then a lot of people
i was quarantined and i just watched
netflix and read books and changed my
whole perspective on everything
and everything was a [ __ ] show covet
politics everything was such a [ __ ]
mess
you know canceled culture pc culture i
was just like oh my god so i this was so
weird and i guess serendipitous but
i had booked a trip to key west florida
i'd been all over the country i've never
been to key west and it was always
something that intrigued me just because
it sounded like you heard it it sounds
beautiful you heard authors musicians so
many people talk about it
so i booked in december forgot about it
and i'm in quarantine going through uh
the news and code what's going on
and
expedia is like hey nick
and i'm like what's up expedia
and they're like remember you've got
your bags packed to key west and i'm
like oh my god so i'm quarantined to my
sister's basement minnesota and it's
been like two it's been like two months
yeah
and i'm like oh [ __ ]
so i call the resort
and um
i was supposed to check in june 3rd this
is what would that be 2020
and i go hey i booked a trip are you
guys open and they're like we open june
2nd and i'm like no [ __ ] way
and i go i'm supposed to fly in june 3rd
and they're like yeah you're good
so i pack my bags and i [ __ ] fly
to uh key west
um i stopped by charleston south
carolina first i said um as i was gonna
move there
and join my friend danny mcbride he's
[ __ ] great i loved him and he's like
gotta move to charleston
and so i went there and i was gonna move
to charleston and i'm like i'll be right
back i'm gonna go to key west and then
i'll come back to charleston
and i went to key west and i stayed for
a [ __ ] year and a half this was a
year i was supposed to be there for 10
days
and i stayed there for a year and a half
and i [ __ ] fell in love with it it
was amazing on every level it was
amazing what'd you love most about it i
loved the people all the friends i made
there
um
uh
taylor sydney todd uh saunders
the retro room which is an arcade there
that's great
um
sandbar sports part so
i just made a ton of friends but it was
so far removed
from everything yeah so when i got
picked up at the airport my friend joe
bachmann great singer
he picks me up
and he goes welcome to the island of
misfit toys
and i go what does that mean and he goes
oh you'll see and i didn't know what
that meant and then the longer i stayed
there it was like so many people had a
story so many people just got away from
the [ __ ] world and like they were
very cognizant of kovid like they took
their temperature they were masked so
you know if you go inside places but it
was still very laid-back very like
bohemian very artsy very just chill it
was just [ __ ] chill and i love the
water in general
so it was just [ __ ] great man and
weather year round yeah the weather was
great and it was just you know drive
around in golf carts and hit the water
man i mean it was just it was awesome
and i fell in love with it and it was
the perfect break and everybody i talked
to back in minnesota and la they're like
don't even come home they're like it's a
[ __ ] show they're like everyone i was
following the news and [ __ ] i got off my
social media and i just was like
i just got my like head back and the
reality and i thought about my life and
perspective and what i want because i
was so frustrated and so like where am i
going what am i doing
and it was a great break it was much
much needed and
and i drank i drank every day you did
yeah totally
i didn't drink like i didn't drink like
i did okay
um i didn't drink to l you know like out
of just complete lunacy
i would just have cocktails you know
what i mean and it was great i [ __ ]
were able to do that and not run them
into day after day after day no i did
day after day
but uh
but i i was smarter about it i was way
smarter about it all right and that
sounds stupid people probably listening
this going like dude you're an idiot
whatever reckless which you know
obviously you can say that but i i
did i knew how to do it where it wasn't
stupid
so you said you really thought about
what you want out of life and all tell
me about that what was your refocus
you're back now so you took a year and a
half off from entertainment and
everything right everything everything i
mean i literally every year the only
thing i did was i did a commercial for
wendy's okay that was on the internet
like i flew back to la got some more
stuff and then came back to key west got
it but for the most part i was i didn't
entertain anything
and excite for yourself you sound like
you really you know got to know nick
swartz and better yeah it was awesome
and like when i was quarantined is when
it first started where i was in my
sister's basement i was reading books i
was reading tons of [ __ ] and i forgot
about reading i hadn't read in forever
and i i just opened my mind up to you
know i turned i was turning 45. so
essentially you could chalk it up to a
midlife crisis essentially but
i
i mean i hope we get 90
yeah
[Music]
i was just like
i just pulled my head out of my ass and
was like hey like
i can't i didn't realize how much i had
accomplished and i never sat back and
was like god i really busted my [ __ ]
ass you're a monster bro but i mean i
never really thought about it like how
like i worked really hard and i was
really frustrated still about certain
things but i was like
enjoy yourself you know what i mean and
like
be good to yourself you know like all
the great times and all the great things
and the roles and my fans have been
awesome i've always been great to my
fans i took [ __ ] 10 all these 10
photos a day with people 12 foot like
all the time i'd take pictures and yeah
i love my fans you know
and so it was just great and i always
have but it was just nice to just be in
like in the setting
and meet so many people and one of the
coolest things my friend um johnny and
richie work at sandbar
and they had a celebrity wall and the
pictures of celebrities that have been
there and i was like hey how come
my pictures you guys don't want a
picture of me
and they were like
because you're nick you're our friend
nick we don't even look at you like
a celebrity we did when you walked in
but you're just nick dude you're just
nick that hangs out and watch games at
the bar
and like that's what i like to be you
know what i mean yeah like i love being
nick swords and then taking photos and
stuff i have a blast with that but it
was just nice that somebody was like
you're just nick cause that's how i am
and that's how like my stand-up is it's
just me when you see me on stage it's
not a character like that's just [ __ ]
it i'm laughing i'm talking about
[ __ ] [ __ ] drinking and whatever
the [ __ ] my grandma do you told this
joke the other night i it just made me
laugh so hard and i don't want to give
your material away but you did this bit
about how you forget when you're not
wearing a mask and you're like look at
this [ __ ] oh yeah guys like you
talking about me and i was telling eva i
said he turned around and [ __ ] said
no i'm serious and you bend over and
spread your cheeks i'll just tell the
jokes
i go people
like get annoyed about wearing masks
and i go i don't mind wearing a mouse
cause like i've gotten used to talking
to myself now so when i wear a mask i
like mumbled to myself which i did
and i go sometimes though i forget i'm
not wearing a mask
and i'll be standing behind somebody and
i'm like god look at this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and the guy would be like excuse me are
you talking to me
and then i have to cover and i'm like
yeah no look at this [ __ ] [ __ ]
like bend over and pretend to pull my
ass apart i'm like do you think i'm sick
of do i have herpes or do i have um yeah
that's blind
do i look
sick yeah looking at your ass
it's so whatever it's stupid but um
but yeah so key west was really great
for me and like i said um now i'm back
i've got all these stand up dates yeah
what do you want what do you want do you
want the same thing before do you still
want to do everything or have you found
have you fallen in love with it all over
again or i fell in love with it all over
again but what i did before was i put so
much pressure on me like i was
developing like five [ __ ] movies at
once and scripts and all this stuff and
it was stuff that i had created and was
trying to write and it's so hard to
write one anything
so i just put so much pressure on myself
and i i just i had to take a step back
and stop doing that
and
i just i had a new act that i was
developing before kobe and i got back
into that
and i love doing stand-up man again my
fans are so
[ __ ] awesome they're so great and
they've been with me for so long i mean
i've been doing it in february 26 years
wow i've been doing stand-up and so
it's great and i've got two movies i
started a movie in february a sequel to
this movie called the binge on hulu
which is really funny and then a movie
that i helped produce and write and star
and called the buddy games we're doing a
sequel to that in july
and it's just great i'm really really
happy and then i'm doing a new special
and i can't talk about that yet but it's
going to be [ __ ] dope really excited
and down the line you are going to start
a podcast right yeah i'm in development
to start a podcast you should yeah it's
i've got a lot of fun ideas for it and
yeah so
i'm really really really happy now and
uh it just took it was nice to just take
a break and
you know like i said it started when i
was in quarantine sober so it wasn't
like i got drunk was like
it was when i was sober and really
focused and
um there's a great book called
self-reliance by ralph waldo emerson
who's a transcendental dude about
existence and who you are and it's an
essay and it's really really great so if
you're bored and you want to read
something that's really interesting
about yourself and just how you just
have to it sounds cliche but just really
believe in yourself and
you know you're important and
you know
i didn't you know and i don't drink all
the time so it's not like
i'm saying that from that mindset well
also i you know there's so much that go
is on your shoulders too you
specifically when you're working and
you're providing jobs for people and
everything it's a lot of stress on you
so i also want to thank you for
something one of the highlights of my
career
um you could have said no but you let me
come in for a table read for uh bucky um
bucky larson bucky larson um and i'm
sitting there and you had me read for
two characters
and i get
laughs in the room
and it felt so good because kurt
russell's sitting right [ __ ] here and
he and i are making eye contact laughing
at these lines and i'm like i can't even
believe sportsman's let me sit here and
do this [ __ ] table read right now it
was so much goddamn fun oh yeah yeah
that's what i'm saying you don't
probably even know that but you've
provided so many people for all these
years dude so thank you and thank you
for coming on here and talking about
this i know it's not easy to open up
like that oh it's super easy i mean i i
well no
well it's just hot this jacket's hot as
[ __ ] dude i'm wearing a long sleeve
minnesota shirt
with a [ __ ] starter dragon with all
these lights
talking about my dead dad
yeah usually it's easy about it what if
i was
and also i'm sweating from alcohol
withdrawal
um but uh yeah so
again i'm glad it was cool having kurt
russell there he couldn't do the movie
but i know he's [ __ ]
around him
um
please one more time here uh promote
everything you'd like
nickswartson.net my stand-up dates will
be up soon i start in orlando so
mid-march orlando naples west palm and
then the key west theater april 3rd all
right i was going to ask if you were
doing key west yeah and then i got
comedy works in denver brea irvine
uh improvs
and then east coast leg minneapolis
possibly uh that's not locked in yet and
then wilbur theater foxwoods whole east
coast run in june
all right and then um cameo app you want
me to do terry or doll for nick or
whatever it's super fun if not and then
this is also a company they don't
sponsor me or anything well they do like
just with items it's called four ocean
i'm a big into the environment and the
ocean i always have been
and uh four oceans on instagram and they
pull tons of trash out of the ocean and
stuff like that right they're really
awesome
and that's it and keep an eye out for
69.
[Music]
69.
as always ryan sickler and all social
media ryan sickler.com we'll talk to you
all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you